coalescent equation the gorillas are the
largest living primates they spend most
of their time on the forest floor eat a
great deal of greenery and lots of fruit
and also climb into the trees we're in
the middle of a king ghost group can go
as a silverback who's used to people
king go has five mates right now they're
up in the trees and King Joe is in the
midst of the underbrush the gorillas are
very important for the rainforest
because they spread the seeds of the
fruit they eat in contribute to
regenerating all the vegetation plants
well
gorillas are the life's work of
scientist Thomas Boyer he studied their
behavior for more than ten years here in
the rainforest along the Congo
they still live relatively undisturbed
pingas core possesses and Kinkos group
is now in a completely primeval forest
and to avoid infecting them with our
human diseases we have to wear masks to
make sure the animals don't catch the
flu or something in their other habitat
which isn't protected massive
deforestation is still taking place not
just selectively but extensively the
trade in bush meat still plays a major
role and so of course does trading live
animals the African rainforest is
important for the Earth's climate
it stores enormous amounts of co2
together Cameroon the Republic of the
Congo and the Central African Republic
have declared 25,000 square kilometres a
protected area there's still a lot to do
time and again the various parties meet
to discuss projects a Leonora Dean is
coordinating the development of the
project on site it's a laborious job
because many regions can be reached only
by boat or on foot
here we're on the sangga River which
crosses the Sangha Tree National
Conservation Area and is in the heart of
the Congo Basin the Congo Basin plays an
important role in terms of preserving
the climate if the Amazon basin is the
first the Congo Basin could be called
the planet's second lung Nora Dean knows
he still has a lot of convincing to do
most people on the edges of the
conservation area see the park as more
of a threat because of the park you have
to at least give the population
financial aid if we hunt we might end up
in prisons people will die children will
no longer be able to attend school the
population lives from the rainforest out
here there's no paid work hardly anybody
earns any money according to the
discussions we've had since the parks
creation the numbers of wild animals
gorillas chimpanzees and elephants have
increased the damage to the people's
fields here has put their survival at
risk that's why they expect compensation
from the park so their villages can
survive
communal forest areas offer some relief
in Cameroon they're located around the
borders of the protected area here
village communities can fell trees
themselves under certain restrictions
and then sell the timber in contrast
professional poaching still poses a huge
problem in the forest gamekeepers can do
little they're not well enough equipped
so success is a rarity we stormed this
camp
unfortunately the poachers had already
fled we found weapons steel traps and
ivory the professional poachers are
heavily armed we have military trainings
but we have no weapons of our own just
six months ago one of them was shot dead
by poachers these are the weapons we've
confiscated they have guns and we don't
but we're trying to keep them in check
anyway Germany alone has allocated about
30 million euros to protect this unique
habitat because preservation of the
rainforests in the Congo Basin is
decisive in the fight against global
warming
further upriver the struggle continues
the government of the Central African
Republic was recently toppled in a coup
since then chaos has reigned throughout
the land
despite that the Tri National Wildlife
Protection troops still try to carry out
their work in the parks for Christian
ended the project leader from the
Central African Republic it's been a
bitter experience in terms of what we've
seen in Sangha Sangha conservation area
the attacks were well organized in early
May poaches probably from Sudan invaded
the clearing called Sangha by the
material damage was great especially the
infrastructure but animals were affected
as well 30 elephants were shot dead
since 2012 the entire Conservation Area
has been a UNESCO World Heritage Site
it's an important if partial victory
increasing the chances that at least
part of the congos green lungs of the
world will be saved from total
exploitation
you